es sumamente preocupante lo que ocurre
hoy día en Guatemala
porque una narrativa de fraude
recordemos que cuando es sin fundamento
es una amenaza para la democracia pero
más grave Aún es la judicialización de
un proceso sin reconocer la voluntad
popular y
con ellos se puede Más bien constituir
una violación a la democracia misma
dejar un proceso electoral en el Limbo
es muy grave y creo que lo más dañino
para un proceso electoral es la
incertidumbre
lo que hay detrás pues históricamente
Guatemala ha sido gobernada por grupos
de poder que han sido vinculados a la
corrupción y al crimen organizado y por
primera vez en mucho tiempo
un candidato social demócrata logra
incluirse en un segundo lugar para
correr en una segunda vuelta electoral
hablaba usted de una amenaza para la
democracia está en riesgo quizás la
segunda vuelta presidencial prevista
para el 20 de agosto
esperemos que no el tribunal supremo
electoral anunció que sí se que se
mantiene la fecha para la segunda vuelta
electoral sin embargo es preocupante que
pese a que ya Se realizaron las
audiencias de revisión y conteo de votos
en las que se reconfirma el resultado
anunciado preliminarmente por el
tribunal supremo electoral el 26
de junio
no se ha confirmado no se han
oficializado los los resultados por
parte del tribunal supremo electoral en
conferencia de prensa hoy la magistrada
del tribunal anunció que estos No pues
no se van a adjudicar los cargos porque
recordemos que se dejaron en suspenso no
solo los resultados a la presidencia
sino también a otros cargos de elección
popular hasta que las Cortes no
certifiquen que ya se cumplió de manera
completa con la instrucción de cotejar
las actas lo cual ya se dio
algunos de los perdedores de las
elecciones en Guatemala están tratando
de abusar del sistema judicial para
obtener los resultados que no pudieron
tener en las boletas Esto es lo que dijo
Juan papier de Human Rights usted
suscribe esta afirmación
Considero que el sistema de justicia en
Guatemala carece de independencia ha
habido un declive democrático en
Guatemala en donde el poder judicial ha
sido penetrado por poderes oscuros que
buscan garantizar impunidad Y creo que
eso ha facilitado que estos partidos
políticos pues utilicen o
instrumentalicen la Justicia con
intereses políticos y para cubrirse de
impunidad en otros casos creo que es
importante mencionar que tanto la misión
de observación electoral de la oea como
la de la Unión Europea manifestaron que
no encontraron pruebas de fraude ni
irregularidades significativas que
pudieran poner en duda el resultado
Entonces es importante que estos
partidos también tuvieron la oportunidad
de
denunciarlo el Día de las elecciones y
no lo hicieron
Ana María Méndez Muchísimas gracias por
su análisis en directo a América en
France 24 en español